we have big breaking news out of
virginia tonight in the commonwealth
where a new fox news poll has republican
glenn younkin surging ahead of democrat
terry mcauliffe by a whopping eight
points remember this is a massive shift
from just two weeks ago where the same
poll had mcauliffe up by five and get
this we're also learning tonight about a
major blunder from the mcculloch
campaign after they mistakenly emailed a
fox news journalist quote can we kill
this when they were inquiring about
whether or not terry mcauliffe hired
attorney with questionable oh let's say
background with a questionable
background mark elias is a clinton
attorney to possibly challenge election
results something both candidates said
they wouldn't do
now there is clearly massive momentum
behind glenn younkin can a deep blue
state like virginia really turn red can
republicans turn out their voters and
deliver a massive political upset here
to make the case republican virginia
gubernatorial candidate glenn younkin is
uh with us uh
it seems like a huge jump statistically
almost impossible
if that poll is accurate or close to
accurate that would mean
late-breaking deciders are breaking hard
for you
and with early voting seeming to be low
and and at you're you're at a pretty
close level with mcauliffe i would say
that gives you an advantage how you
feeling about it
we're feeling great sean i mean we're
out on day six of our 10-day bus tour
the crowds are amazing we just had a
giant event in augusta county we had
over a thousand people there's energy on
this campaign it's no longer a campaign
it's a momentum
it's it is absolutely a movement it's a
movement to stand up for virginians for
parents and to reject government control
and terry mcauliffe has demonstrated
that he cares more about his own career
than he does for virginians he wants to
put government between parents and their
children and if he doesn't like the
answer then all of a sudden the fbi
comes in and tries to silence him this
is our moment as virginians to come
together we're winning the independent
vote by double digits we have democrats
walking across the aisle in droves and
what you're seeing in these polls is
exactly what we're feeling on the road
you know you you look at all the people
mcauliffe has brought in unpopular joe
biden 35 percent kamala harris stacy
abrams
even barack obama
at terry's own events he seems to be
getting more press appearing than people
showing up for his events i think the
maximum crowd they had with biden and
obama was less than 2 000 um and you're
drawing huge crowds everywhere you go so
anecdotally you're feeling good about it
how do you analyze the early voting
yeah so the so first of all terry
mcauliffe's doing exactly what the
playbook that he wrote as the godfather
of the modern day
democratic party would do which is bring
somebody else in he's asked everybody to
come in to campaign if you've ever held
office and won or didn't win he's
invited you to come in to take the
spotlight off of his failed record as
governor and his failure to lay forward
an agenda that embraces virginians and
i'll tell you this early voting has been
great the turnout for us has been strong
the turnout for him has been weak i mean
i've said it all along the only person
excited about terry terry mcauliffe is
terry mcauliffe and sean the big thing
is this race has become a national race
virginians are voting for the nation i
get so many emails and and texts every
day our website at
younkinforgovernor.com is absolutely
almost overwhelmed by folks coming in
and being part of what is going to not
just change the future of this great
commonwealth of virginia but it's going
to set a shock across the bow for the
entire country that we're going to take
our country back
so
a one of our reporters for fox news i
believe dot com
says he's writing a story about
mcauliffe hiring mark elias
now what's interesting about this
a friend of this program jonathan turley
tweeting out
they're a host of election lawyers but
mcauliffe selected an attorney accused
of lying to the media advancing rejected
conspiracy theories currently involved
in a major federal investigation that
has already led to an indictment of his
former partner mcauliffe may be
preparing to challenge any win by glenn
younkin
and the response was they didn't mean to
do it
but they write can we get this story
killed can we try to kill this what is
your reaction to the hiring of elias and
the campaign
obviously feels that they have an in
with certain media outlets that they can
get stories killed
well first of all this just is the exact
playbook that terry mcauliffe wrote for
the modern day democratic party and his
campaign is absolutely failing i mean
the sun is setting on his 43-year
political career and by the way they're
not going to need lawyers because this
isn't going to be close what's happening
in virginia today with with us winning
independence by double digits and
democrats walking across the aisle and
voting for us this isn't going to be
close sean virginians are making a big
statement we're making a statement that
there's a new day ahead of us low taxes
the best schools the best jobs safe
communities and a government that works
for us and isn't telling us what to do
all the time these are universal values
and virginians are ready to step forward
and make this race not even close it
really would be nice to have a governor
that actually likes parental involvement
in kids education age-appropriate
materials being taught crt
draconian measures as it relates to
covet et cetera et cetera and not being
lectured that they have no business uh
being involved in their children's
education i didn't think that was a very
good line by mcauliffe we're going to be
watching very closely five days glenn
younkin thank you for being with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else